j'ai été diplômé de l'université,
j'ai travaillé chez Ford pendant quelques années.
Après, j'ai travaillé dans l'église Jésus Christ des Saints du Dernier Jour
puis je suis retourné à Salt Lake City.
Pendant cette période, j'ai été envoyé
dans le plus grand centre pour sans-abris de l'État
pour les aider à développer et améliorer
leurs compétences en finance et management.
Là-bas, j'ai découvert une nouvelle approche comportementale
vis-à-vis des individus sans-abri,
et des drogués.
Il s'agit du modèle de réduction des risques.
Il consiste à fournir des seringues stériles et des préservatifs.
Et je pensais : « Quelle idée stupide ! »
(Rires)
« Ça va juste les encourager à persister dans ce comportement.
Dites-leur juste de s'arrêter. »
Quelques années plus tard, j'ai découvert les premiers plans sur 10 ans
pour aider les sans-abris
proposés par le gouvernement.
En lisant ces plans, j'ai pensé :
« Pfff ! Ce n'est pas réaliste.
On ne peut pas tous les aider.
Il y a trop de choix personnels et de facteurs que l'on ne contrôle pas. »
Mon point de vue a quand même changé,
quand j'ai assisté à une conférence en 2003,
où j'ai découvert les raisons à l'origine du plan sur 10 ans.
D'abord, il y avait cette petite population de sans-abris,
qui ne représentait que 15% mais coûtait très cher.
C'est compréhensible
pour un État conservateur comme l'Utah.
La deuxième raison vient du modèle « Un chez-soi d'abord »,
ou accès simplifié au logement.
Il y a un organisme à New-York
qui a proposé aux sans-abris souffrant de problèmes mentaux
de quitter la rue pour vivre dans un logement.
Et ils étaient toujours autorisés à se droguer, et à boire,
tout comme nous dans nos logements.
En plus, il y avait des services proposés -- qui restaient facultatifs --
par les tuteurs,
pour les aider à s'approprier leurs nouvelles conditions de vie
et se stabiliser.
Ils utilisaient le modèle de réduction des risques.
J'étais plus que sceptique au départ en entendant parler de ce modèle,
mais ils avaient un taux de réussite impressionnant :
85% d'entre eux étaient encore hébergés après 12 mois.
La troisième raison
était l'importance de développer une relation de confiance.
A cause des abus que ces individus avaient subis
au cours de leur vie,
ils n'avaient plus confiance en personne.
Et les seringues propres, les préservatifs, l'accès au logement,
étaient des moyens pour initier une relation de confiance.
C'est vital.
Alors lors de mon retour de cette conférence,
assis dans l'avion, je regardais par le hublot,
et j'ai réalisé que ma compréhension de la condition des sans-abris
était en train de changer.
Et tout en regardant par le hublot,
j'ai eu le sentiment profond
que s'il y avait bien un État [aux E.U.]
qui pouvait aider les sans-abris chroniques,
c'était bien l'Utah.
Parce que nous avons ce sentiment sous-jacent
de désir et de volonté de venir en aide à son prochain,
y compris les sans-abris.
Et puis j'ai commencé à visualiser comment on pourrait faire cela.
Ceux qui ont assisté à la conférence disaient :
« Ces modèles fonctionneront dans l'Utah. »
Mais à notre retour, certains disaient :
« Non, ça ne marchera pas. Pas ici en tout cas. »
Pourtant, il y avait un organisme qui fournit des logements sociaux
qui était prêt à construire nos 100 premiers.
Mais ils étaient inquiets de réunir 100 personnes sans-abris chroniques
au même endroit.
Pour les rassurer, nous avons décidé de créer un chantier pilote
pour tester cette idée, pendant la construction des 100 logements.
On allait utiliser des logements existants dispersés dans Salt Lake City.
Puis on s'est demandé :
devrions-nous sélectionner des sans-abris autonomes
ou bien les cas les plus complexes ?
C'est là que mon passé de fermier m'a aidé à trancher.
A cette époque, ma mère cuisinait nos repas
et chauffait l'eau pour notre bain hebdomadaire
sur un poêle à bois et à charbon.
Et après avoir fendu du bois pendant toutes ces années,
j'ai appris qu'il vaut mieux commencer par les gros rondins
tant qu'on a encore de l'énergie.
Alors on a décidé d'utiliser l'approche des « gros rondins d'abord »
en choisissant 17 personnes parmi les plus délicates,
et dans la plus grande précarité, que nous pouvions aider.
Parce qu'on savait qu'on en apprendrait beaucoup plus avec eux.
22 mois plus tard,
les 17 vivaient toujours dans leur maison.
Y compris Keta,
qui aujourd'hui, 11 ans plus tard,
dort dans son propre lit,
et est sobre.
A la fin de ce pilote, une jeune tutrice a dit :
« Il nous arrivait de débattre quand j'étais à l'université
sur les meilleures techniques de tutorat.
Aujourd'hui, notre théorie est la suivante :
Il faut tout faire pour les garder logés. »
On en est devenus adeptes.
Nous avons construit des centaines de logements les 10 années suivantes,
ce qui a permis de réduire la population de sans-abris chroniques de l'État
de 91%.
Mais au fait, qui sont les sans-abris?
Beaucoup de gens veulent juste les voir partir, disparaitre,
qu'ils ne les dérangent pas.
Au cours de ces 10, 11 ans de projet, j'ai reçu beaucoup d'explications
sur la manière de devenir sans-abri.
L'une d'elles m'est apparue il y a quelques années
quand je faisais une ronde avec l'équipe d'aide sociale.
Ils travaillent sur le terrain,
et se rendent auprès des sans-abris et des prostituées,
pour vérifier leur état de santé.
Un des membres de l'équipe
m'expliquait que 8 des prostituées avaient donné naissance à 31 enfants
qui étaient devenus pupilles de la nation.
Il disait aussi que certains proxénètes étaient leurs maris,
et pire encore,
leurs pères.
On attendait de ces prostituées,
à la fin de leur adolescence, et dans leur vingtaine, trentaine,
qu'elles gagnent chaque jour assez d'argent pour couvrir
une addiction à l'héroïne à 100$ par jour,
leurs dépenses quotidiennes
et leur proxénète.
Et avec des rapports non protégés, elles gagnent plus,
mais sans surprise, elles peuvent tomber enceintes.
Les enfants qui naissent dans ces conditions finissent souvent sans-abri.
Et ce n'est pas possible de rencontrer quelqu'un né dans ces circonstances,
ou un parent qui rend son enfant accro aux drogues à 7 ans,
ou une génération de bébés nés dans l'addiction aux drogues,
sans ressentir de la détresse.
Pour ma part, je pense que chaque personne a de la valeur,
peu importe qui elle est.
Et ce n'est pas envisageable de juger quelqu'un qui démarre sa vie comme ça,
et de lui en vouloir pour ce qu'il est devenu.
(Applaudissements)
Personne ne grandit en disant : « Plus tard, je serai sans-abri. »
Et c'est la force du modèle de réduction des risques et de « Un chez-soi d'abord ».
Ils prennent en compte la complexité des différents facteurs
qui construisent la vie d'un être humain.
Ces modèles se mettent au niveau des personnes telles qu'elles sont,
pas telles que nous sommes,
ou telles qu'on pense qu'elles devraient être.
Le pilote mené avec ces 17 personnes nous a appris bien des choses.
Quand les gens ont vécu dans la rue pendant plusieurs années,
revenir vivre dans un logement
demande un long apprentissage.
Et Donald
nous a donné quelques leçons de transition.
Son tuteur lui a demandé pourquoi il n'avait pas mis de chauffage
dans son appartement glacé.
Donald a dit : « Comment on fait ? »
On lui a montré le thermostat.
Le tuteur a également remarqué
qu'il réchauffait les haricots directement dans la conserve sur le feu,
comme il faisait dans les camps pendant des années.
On lui a montré des casseroles et des poêles.
On a aussi appris qu'il avait une sœur qu'il n'avait pas vue depuis 25 ans,
et qui pensait qu'il était mort.
Elle fut ravie d'apprendre le contraire,
et ils se sont très vite revus.
Des centaines de personnes comme Keta et Donald ont maintenant un logement,
et revoient leur famille.
De plus, nos collectivités affichent
une baisse des frais de leurs services d'urgence.
J'ai appris, jour après jour,
que quand on écoute l'histoire d'une personne à cœur ouvert,
et que l'on se met à sa place,
on ne peut l'aider qu'avec de l'amour et de l'attention,
mais on veut l'aider.
C'est pour cela que je me suis engagé
à continuer d'apporter de l'espoir et de l'aide à nos citoyens sans-abri,
que je considère aujourd'hui comme mes frères et sœurs.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)